a top 16 entry at the world cheese
awards in november 2016
native australian ants which lend a
lemony flavor you're telling me there's
ants on this
[Music]
hi i'm joel kimbuster and i'm about to
go on a shopping spree with gq
[Music]
water
wow we're really just going there there
is some fancy water aqua de cristalo
trebuto
uh
mode
well that's a mouthful sixty thousand
dollars per 750 milliliters contains
water from natural springs in fiji
france and iceland okay so it's sort of
like a suicide you know that thing where
you like go to the fountain and you fill
it up with diet coke coke cherry coke
sprite this is the water equivalent of
that bottled in a 24 karat gold bottle
designed by fernando altamirano i'm
famous for decorating my apartment with
empty water bottles they're all over the
place it'd be kind of chic to have like
a nice looking water bottle for a change
kona negari water 402 per 750
milliliters now this looks like a little
drug you know
it's desalinated hawaiian deep sea water
harvested 2000 feet below the ocean off
the coast of hawaii contains naturally
occurring deep ocean electrolytes
aids weight loss stress reduction skin
tone and digestion
the thing about all the things
that it says it's going to do you know
it's all stuff that's like hard to
actually
like qualify skim me the water off the
top i don't need deep sea water do you
know what's down there do you know
what's in the deep sea [ __ ] up [ __ ]
philico black queen jewelry water ooh i
like the look of this one 1053
sourced from a well deep under the rocco
mountains in kobe japan the bottles are
masterpieces combining glass with gold
inlay and the famous swarovski crystals
does it come in the little crown and
these these little wings or is that just
on the bottle i love a water bottle that
comes with an accessory they're always
talking about like where the water is
coming from and i have i have never i
think you reach a certain
like level of wealth and suddenly you
start talking about the difference in
the way water tastes it's water i don't
care where it comes from i don't need it
fancier than fiji certainly but it's
cute and i like it tasmanian rain oh
five dollars per 750 milliliters pure
rain water from the island of tasmania i
just said i didn't give a [ __ ] where the
water came from but now that you're
telling me it's coming from the [ __ ]
sky the sky's above tasmania where the
devil is from i have paid more than five
dollars for water that has come from the
airport i think the answer is pretty
clear where i'm going here i'm just
dropping five bucks on that tasmanian
rain
give me the tasmanian rain
box sets ooh let's check out some box
sets box sets what a throwback the thing
that is missing from streaming is all
the bonus features i prefer actor
commentaries to the director
commentaries i don't need to know how
you set up the shot but i want to know
who's pulling pranks on set so the first
box set is sailor moon for 240 dollars
the original 1995 english dub and theme
song dvds and vhs's are no longer in
production which is a real bummer this
is my [ __ ] this is my jam the soapiness
of it the sci-fi
ness of it like the action of it i was
obsessed it's gonna be hard to beat this
one rupaul's drag race all stars
140
the first season of all-stars
terrible famously terrible that's why
they started bringing them back and
letting them compete again because it
was a total mulligan it didn't count
rupaul if you're watching it was a
failure but she really kicked it up all
stars 2 is probably the best season of
the show and the thing is about like all
this stuff living on streaming is like
who knows it's all house of cards who
knows how long anything's gonna be
lasting on streaming so it would be nice
to have like a physical copy real
housewives of atlanta now this is a
winner this is to me the franchise that
put the entire thing like really into
the stratosphere and they are the
funniest they are the funniest bar none
like there's a lot of laughing at
housewives in the other franchises this
is a lot of laughing with them and
finally will and grace 249
includes eight seasons plus an exclusive
episode booklet and bonus disc with
newly recorded commentaries with cast
and crew this show is huge for me like
when i'm on the road in a hotel room the
first thing i do when i wake up is turn
to lifetime because 90 chance they will
be playing an old episode of will and
grace i think i'm gonna have to go with
sailor moon only because it's the least
accessible i think everything else i
could probably find pretty easily 240
bucks easy
real estate i just became a homeowner
myself so this should be interesting oh
wow a house on fire island
fire island beach cottage one million
five hundred thousand dollars i've just
spent the last six months looking at
real estate in la this seems pretty
reasonable that's so cool i have always
wanted to buy a house that will not
exist in 10 years because of global
warming it's hard to tell like where
it's at on the island the exterior is
not doesn't doesn't give like that
classic fire island feel to me but the
interior definitely does um like all
wood interior
built in 1906
okay so it's seen a lot of sex only 1.5
bathrooms though that's tough where are
people going to do drugs you know if
there's a party
hollywood hills party house 11 million
dollars now see that seems more familiar
this is crazy so eight levels six
bedrooms four baths a pool nightclub
casino lounge and state-of-the-art
screening room the outside is giving
like it's sort of like this brutalist
like exterior i don't love it it's not
super inviting i love this like goofy
tron shower i don't know
who came up with that but it's
definitely a vibe it seems like it was
meant for that point in the after party
where five people want to take a shower
together san francisco condo three
million six hundred and ninety five
thousand dollars built in 1908 ooh
baby baby baby san francisco is one of
my favorite cities i don't think there's
another city that looks quite like san
francisco i should move there because
people at parties need to meet someone
who doesn't work in tech it's giving
full house a little bit on the outside
but not full full house you're not
living in the full house house it's so
weird the outside of the house is giving
like funky eclectic classic san
francisco san francisco in the 60s and
70s like when it was cool
and then the inside is giving you know
anthropology it's like and this is what
san francisco has become but
you know
i can change that by moving into this
three and a half million dollar home
downtown naperville bower mansion two
million nine hundred and fifty thousand
dollars the inside looks like every
house
that i like
visited when i was growing up like all
my friends houses like i bet this has a
dope finished basement with a sectional
couch i grew up in this the poor city
next to naperville naperville at one
point had the richest school district in
the nation and we
were right next door they hired the
people who did the beijing olympics
opening ceremonies to do their special
effects for the wizard of oz that's the
kind of people we're dealing with here i
really
wanted something like this but looking
at it now i'm sort of like
it would have to be a lot cheaper for me
to move back to downtown naperville i
think it's down to the fire island beach
cottage and the san francisco condo and
quite honestly both of those are in
danger from the elements and climate
change like we've got do i want to go in
sort of like slow but steady as the tide
sort of roll up to my house and take it
under the ocean or do i want to go in
the big one and so i'm gonna go with the
fire island beach cottage live hard live
fast
[Music]
self-care we're gonna check out some
self-care products which
i need a lot of new body microcurrent
device
four hundred dollars now you love it
when it's just called a device
new faces exclusive micro four
technology again meaningless to me
targets stubborn areas to help smooth
away the look of dimpled uneven skin i
still don't quite understand what it's
for it feels like it's trying to confuse
me with the words and the ingredients
and the the functionality of it to the
point that i don't think this is
something that would work for anybody
earwax removal tool 28
this is both arousing and scary this
tool provides a camera image that is
transmitted to a smartphone so you can
see what you're doing oh my god comes
with ear safe silicone tips to avoid
scratching the ear canal okay that was
my next question so answered this is
huge i have more pictures of the back of
my throat than i do dick pics on my
phone right now okay my only worry is
that i would overdo it i'd be sticking
that thing in all my orifices every
goddamn day
blood cream fourteen hundred dollars
the process involves a small blood draw
followed by heating incubating and high
speed centrifuging that separ separates
a plasma broth that now contains hugely
amplified healing factors and other
proteins the plasma and is then injected
into dr sturm's proprietary base cream
to form the most personalized skin cream
in existence i've actually had something
similar done i've done the the vampire
facial where they like micro needle your
face and then they take your blood and
sep and do exactly what this does it
doesn't say like the dimensions or like
how much we're actually getting in here
i can't believe i'm
waffling on blood cream but i am baby
foot exfoliation peel restore dry
cracked and callous feet with baby foot
original foot peel exfoliator confusing
because i would see the brand baby foot
and i'd say not for me i'm a big boy
foot i got big boy feet i don't like
feet i'm not a feet person i have no
interest in making my foot more
appealing to someone who's in defeat
no i'm gonna become a little blood pup
for barbara stern okay and i'll tell you
why it's not the earwax thing because
that's 28 bucks i'm ordering that thing
as soon as we wrap if you're looking to
get me a gift
get me barbara sturm's blood cream
[Music]
cheese okay wow
out blossom cheese 40 per pound why does
this look like a birthday cake this
wheel gets coated in a mix of local
flora including marigold rose petals
lavender and chervil okay listen
my favorite restaurant is subway you're
putting something called chervil on my
cheese
no five pounds baby swiss wheel
eighteen hundred and fifty dollars for a
lot of five champion of the championship
cheese auction the original baby swiss
is delightfully mild and creamy and
loved by all i don't know man like it
feels like i can get swiss anywhere i
can get swiss
you guessed it at subway all right and
you're telling me i gotta pay 18.50 for
this stuff seems a little suspect let's
move on artisan anthill goat cheese 18
again this cheese is covered in [ __ ] a
top 16 entry at the world cheese awards
in november 2016. native australian ants
which lend a lemony flavor you're
telling me there's ants on this [ __ ] i
could just go and buy a hump of goat
cheese and set it outside my my porch
and boom cover to dance this is [ __ ]
up wheel of parmigiano reggiano
2
9999
made in the amelia romagna region of
italy this aromatic parmigiano reggiano
weighs approximately 80 pounds i kind of
get why it's 3 000 because it is 80
pounds i would love to do one of those
things where they scoop out the middle
and make the the cheese the bowl that
sounds dope and you know emilia romagna
she sounds like she's going to win an
oscar next year we're going to go with
my girl amelia the wheel of
parmigiano-reggiano for 2 999 why not um
if anything i can put it on my coffee
table it looks beautiful and that is
that i'm joel kimbuster and that is what
is in my shopping cart if you want you
can check out my new movie fire island
which comes out june 3rd on hulu or you
can check out my new stand-up special
coming to netflix called psychosexual
that's out on june 21st thanks for the
shopping spree gq
[Music]